more women are speaking out about
alleged sexual harassment by Hollywood
mogul
Harvey Weinstein the latest bombshell
allegations in the New York Times come
from stars like Gwyneth Paltrow and
Angelina Jolie as well as other
actresses Paltrow is told the time she
was harassed by Weinstein when she was
22 years old she says that he suggested
they go to a hotel bedroom for massages
Paltrow later told Brad Pitt who was her
boyfriend at the time who then
confronted Harvey Weinstein in an email
to The Times Jolie said Weinstein made
unwanted advances in a hotel room and
she quote chose never to work with
Harvey again and warned others when they
did Weinstein was fired Sunday by his
company four of nine board members
resigned as a result of the original
revelations New York Times correspondent
Jody Kanter is a CBS News contributor
she co-authored the article that broke
this story
Jody good morning good morning this has
been incredible reporting tell me about
how you got Gwyneth Paltrow and Angelina
Jolie to reveal this abuse from a while
ago they wanted to come forward in the
wake of the first story we broke they
wanted to support other women they
winneth said to me we need to send a
message this kind of behavior towards
women ends now there are also reports in
other places about that things that go
beyond simply harassment and threatening
most sexual violence is just the tip of
the iceberg we're saying is there some
sense that there are a lot of other
things coming out in this story we are
in the process of understanding the
scope and the span of what appears to
have happened here and I think that in
terms of the really serious allegations
that you're discussing and also in terms
of Gwyneth Paltrow and Angelina Jolie
coming forward I think we're all asking
the question of you know let's look at
30 years of movie history here what were
we really watching on screen what were
we really watching at the Oscars and
what kind of behavior was a covering up
you know from the very first time you
were at the table with the story and we
asked you at the very end is there more
to come and you said we'll see well we
are certainly now seeing a lot Jody
Cantor and one other thing that stands
out is the board members who are
paraphrasing now they said they're
shocked and appalled and they had no
idea about this type of behavior and
then based on your reporting we're here
it's an open secret what do you make of
the Board's comment about that I will
tell your story about The Weinstein
Company so in 2015 Lauren O'Conner a
junior executive writes a stem-winder of
a memo about sexual harassment she
basically becomes an internal
whistleblower she authors this very long
report very well documented a lot of
dates a lot of names she describes very
disturbing incidents including a
colleague being forced to give Harvey
Weinstein a massage when he was naked in
a hotel room and she sends it off to
executives at the company board members
and while the question becomes what is
going to happen to address this so the
board does get a notification that there
is a complaint against Harvey and
they're told coming to the office this
is serious come take a look at it and
then they're told right afterwards oh
the complaint has been withdrawn now
what really happened is that powerful
lawyer stepped in and Lauren O'Conner
took a settlement meaning she took
compensation for what happened to her
and what she was documenting but then
she agreed to stay silent on the matter
so should those board members have
pursued things further at that point and
who are the board members the board
members are who so first of all this is
an all-male board yeah and these were
mostly people who were very close to
Harvey Weinstein but in fact the board
is saying that this was a utter surprise
is the exact word they're using the idea
that this was an utter surprise let me
just show a clip from the Oscars and
Seth MacFarlane joking about that these
were the nominations let's listen
congratulations you five ladies no
longer have to pretend to be attracted
to Harvey Weinstein
that joke that joke and the laughter
afterwards and the thing I want to make
clear is that that was in early 2013
some of the abuses the allegations of
abuses that we chronicled took place in
2014 and 2015 so here people are
laughing about it in public and then the
behavior appears to have been going on
afterwards
what do we know about Harvey and and his
lawyers in terms of what they are doing
in response to all this because there
was a report tonight last night that
Harvey Weinstein was at some sex
addiction addiction clinic in Europe
well their response to us on the story
we published yesterday about the casting
couch was very minimal they basically
denied any non-consensual sex and they
said we don't want to talk about it
anymore he's not going to be taking any
more questions he's going to be spending
time with his family
as a brother do you think leading the
charge against him they're stories about
that I think that you know my impression
based on the reporting is that Bob
Weinstein is trying to save their
company they're giving it a different
name they're trying to maintain these
deals they have with other powerful
companies been incredible reporting by
you and your colleagues at the New York
Times thank you for being there that
sounds like there's more to come from
you Joey canter thank you thank you very
much